Hey, welcome to the Android
developer nanodegree.
My name's Chris, and I'm a curriculum
manager here at Udacity.
I'm lucky to have worked on some cool
Android devices, like the Nexus,
and the Samsung Galaxy series.
More importantly,
I love building mobile products.
They're increasingly more personal,
enrich our lives in so many ways,
and they even feel a tad magical.
Now today, I'm super excited to help
you begin your journey to build and
create your own immersive experiences
for this incredible platform.
Now it's even cooler is we designed this
degree with our friends at Google, so
you know that you're learning
directly from the experts.
I think they want to say, hello.
>> Hi.
>> And you learn about Android
as a platform for your ideas and
become aware of the vast canvas of
APIs that will be at your disposal.
Before you know it, you're writing
code that can reach millions of people
not only on their phones but also on
their tablet's, TVs, wearables and
even in their cars and when you finish
the program, you'll be ready to start or
advance your career as
an Android developer.
You'll even have a killer
portfolio projects to prove it.
So why don't we go through them.
You'll get your feet wet with an
introductory project that you'll build
in the first week in the nanodegree.
You'll also build an app that helps
users discover the most popular movies
on the web, an optimizer for
both phone and tablet.
Next, you'll take two apps and make them
production ready by adding features like
Google Cloud Messaging, error handling,
widgets, accessibility and localization
support, and a handy one that are
properly used in integrated libraries.
After that,
we timed the superchargeable process
using the gridable system to automate
testing, signing, dependency management,
and even configuring your app to
build a free and payed version.
Okay, then you're going to focus on
something that's critical to every app,
the user experience, something
that we all evaluate visceraly.
You're going to take an existing app and
update it using Android's latest
design language, material design.
You'll even learn how to extend your
apps to wearables, TV, and the car.
Finally, you'll take everything you
learned from building these projects
to develop a unique app experience
of your own in the Capstone project.
Your app will also draw from Google's
extensive set of mobile services, which
includes things like maps, location and
context, analytics and AdMob.
Here's Miriam to tell you more
about details of the program.
>> Building these
projects won't be easy.
We are going to challenge you so
that you are prepared to solve tough
problems and think independently.
To rise to that challenge, you'll need
to keep up with your learning schedule
and engage with your
nanodegree community.
Your fellow students are here to
help untangle the trickiest puzzles,
get over the biggest hurdles, and
encourage you through all of it.
And when they need help
you'll do the same for them.
The Audacity team will be here
too to deepen your learning,
offer project feedback, and
help you develop professionally.
By leveraging the support systems and
working consistently, you can prepare
yourself for an entirely new stage of
your career in a matter of months.
We can't wait to see where
your nanodegree takes you.